so so when this was built as a open
session i i foolishly thought we were
going to spend time discussing
uh
open questions
i mean so there's three
maybe people could suggest some more
yeah yeah yeah i'd be very interested
okay
yeah yeah
so
i wasn't sure what the format of this
would be but
i mean
so with
the possibility of writing obviously i
want to
talk about two things which already came
up
so one is the point i keep repeating to
any audience like this i mean many of
them are anywhere crazy
uh
maybe it looks more and more like the
terminal is hard and we should
understand
objects and similar polynomials and if
you think from the point of view of
computational complexity theory we
cannot
even move slower bounds for
things that look like this
and we have
products of linear form but these are
fine
as far as we know
it's possible that
the
and
or
even permanent them
it's much more outrageous than
determining
itself it's possible that you can embed
them
with the you know just any
things you were any audio
but we know
you can compute the terminal and
permanent just by
a formula of polynomial size
of depth 3
which looks like this and just has a
fine forms in the
in the variable it's outrageous and we
should prove that that's impossible so
we don't know how to so let me give you
an easier problem
follow from the fact that
the elementary symmetric polynomial
so i basically want you to study these
guys as opposed to the term
job is closure of this guy
uh where is it exactly okay you
understood the orbit
you know these are polynomials which
look complicated they have exponentially
many monomials
but nevertheless there is a very simple
there is a very simple
formula like this
the very firm simple formula just with
the
and
so despite the fact that this is
complicated for the army
uh i mean i can show you this
very good
but because of that
an even easier question to ask is uh
you're answering him uh jordan are you
answering yeah
i can answer everybody
just let me finish the sentence then i
can show you
because
because this can be done
an even easier question to ask is can
you embed the terminator permanent with
your favorite foreign
into the symmetric
polynomial of thinner form so can you
write that
m
as a symmetric
elementally symmetric polynomial
but
what kind of lower bounds for n k would
make you happy
so you cannot do it for
n and k polynomials in them
yeah yeah
yeah well k is less than n so you cannot
do it
for n which is uh polynomial so these
are s
offering forms it's very important that
i find
uh joseph talked about the method of
partial derivatives which is the the
baby
version of everything that the other
layer was doing is something that norm
nissan i did long ago you can use it to
show that if you
restrict yourself to
homogeneous linear form without constant
then there is an exponential double bond
on embedding even the terminal
but once you allow constants and now
i'll answer your question because you'll
see the power of constant
uh
you can
you can get polynomial size formulas for
these they are mentally similar
maybe i don't know but definitely
so
i just want to say that this is just a
question of whether
whether the determinant
is contained in the determining of them
is contained in the action of the fine
group
on
acting on the symmetric
polynomial
it's the same kind of question you we
keep asking i mean the whole week we
were asking about the terminal it's a
much simpler
i don't think normally polynomial orbit
closure of that doesn't contain any
nasty stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's
a it's a great question whether your
conjunction about the office closer
i mean yeah yeah so you especially is a
great conjecture which in fact
i don't think it will be easy but i you
know i think it's much more doable than
for the terminal so
so i'm suggesting this may ask the
notation does any
yeah
any polynomial in
so you want to show this
and what is the end what kind of group
oh no this is just a fine group so you
find
the translation
actually so you just uh
well this is the way i like to express
it just write it for the
the immediate function of applied form
an elementary symmetric function
elemental isometric form
one of the elementary symmetry functions
no loss of generality
i think the other similar thing is that
for diagonal three circuits which a lot
of geometers know about
it does not contain points with
block in the cervix yeah i should have
mentioned that even simpler objects when
the metallic symmetric polynomials are
just a diagonal sum of powers and for
that queen we have lower
no but on the boundary on the boundary i
don't know actually yeah
and
the determinant is on the
uh
one column no it is this okay yeah yeah
for me it's less natural but maybe for
you it's moment you have to think about
it this way anyway yeah so there are
simple polynomials to study and to study
that and so on now for those who
uh want to see this is also really magic
very simple so here's the circuit
it comes from the fact that uh you all
know that if i take some life i have my
variables x one two x and i want another
one of the elementary symmetric
polynomials in it i'll compute them all
in fact
so i take some variable t
and i look at this product
this is just simply the sum of the
symmetric
okay and here we have whatever
so this is
in the x-axis
that's obvious
but that's great this is this is the
circuit you see the circuit
so
the
the the multiplication gates i'll tell
you what they're looking at so we'll
have uh
n plus one multiplication gate or we
look like this
um
so here we will
say
we take this will
be responsible for
here i do i multiply one plus x one
one plus x n
and here i multiply
m
i need the field to be
larger than that
i just evaluate this for different
values of t now what do i put here
but if i have all these values i have
evaluations of this at 10 plus one point
already
i can't tell you what there is some
concept
okay that's that's
fine
right
okay so if the squared
is an s well size
formula for that
method
but i don't understand you ask us to
express the determinant as a symmetric
polynomial in linear form and you just
say that above that that's hard yeah no
so what i'm saying this is the way to do
the symmetric elementary symmetric ones
and i wanted to show that nothing like
this could work all right
so you can start like we always start
with easier problems and try to say well
maybe
maybe if they are two or three or
constant it cannot be done and niraj
has a
new result uh showing that if this is
small let's say constant this requires
exponential cells
but this exponential low bound breaks
down when when the final growth
i don't know
the other thing i mentioned during uh
gender stocks i'm not going to write
anything down i'll just say it again
uh all the low bound methods we
succeeded
for some classes of circuits
uh
have a you know common framework the
common framework is that we take
one time
all the ones that were successful and
also
many of the ones that are that joseph
described that are being attempted by
various people
all these young fleshenings and all
these
other things they they have the same
form they take if we take i know p's
and variables and degrees so these are
all polynomials
all polynomials
and values valuable
i know your homogeneous is zero
but it doesn't matter anyway we have
this space
and we take
a linear mapping from physical subjects
whatever
and
uh the way we prove low balancing we
let's say for
you know for polynomial p we want to say
that the dimension
of l of p
is bigger than the dimension of anything
trying to compute it it can be a family
of circuits it can be the closure of
determinants under you know it's just a
search opinion also
bigger than the dimension
of
both of you in some class which is what
we are trying to
uh you know
that's how they work
i think it's a it's a great question so
so partial delivery is like this and the
shifted ones are like the shifting
social derivatives and the projects that
shift the partial derivatives are like
that and the young flattening side like
that
and
it's so this is upper semiconductor that
the dimension image can you know drop
and one question i don't know the answer
question it's a great question i think
the feeling i'm i have and maybe just
share the same feeling
is that the now next may not be enough
so it's a you know it would be a great
question to say that no matter what
linearity you just study it in complete
generality no matter what linear maps
you can you cannot use it to separate
permanent from determining
your map with that dimension you look at
the tangent space exactly i
so excuse me if you have a non-linear
map of that property then you look at
the tangent space
yeah so why why would you be better than
that or even non-linear maps can be
completely changed into linear map by
equal to symmetric
formulas or just
you know translations of determinants of
small size the polynomial side
um then
yeah so you can study it specifically
you know here's the specific question i
i didn't think about so maybe i'm not
stating it right but something like that
doesn't exist an error for which
the dimension of
the the terminal you need actually the
government
the permanent
permanent
is bigger
than the dimension
of anything
any cure
in whatever
that's how you know
and
so in the open close of the of the
determinants
is there any map which will distinguish
i don't know i mean that's a concrete
question and this here
that it's not the same question to move
to you know if i replace it by some
polynomial
yeah and i don't know what it would even
mean it's the polynomial map and it will
not be a vector space but
yeah i just i should say
i mean what
what this map
we have some fixed uh
vector space and what we are mapping is
to subspaces outside
we are
we are mapping polynomials to subspaces
that's what happens in all this uh
understanding because that's a family
yeah very good
so yeah and that's a complete question
maybe it's not precisely formulated but
i would love to know but
but the way that it works is that that's
sort of continuous man of polynomials
yeah
so so um
writers
well yeah it's
the most continuity
so do you have something specific in
mind
no i i i i
can't look at it
i don't know maybe
when we fail to prove something we
try to
look for the reason namely pool
that all the methods we use so far fail
there's a history of such things and
some of you have heard of net
opportunities
various uh things like this so
this would be you know maybe this is not
this technique in general no matter what
kind of you know
algebraic geometric intuition you have
it would
be now is nothing i don't know
i don't think
because
yeah it's i think i can say it
foreigners
so it's too bad because frank leckerman
will be here but he's not here at the
moment this is really a question for him
so
there's this far variety of the
veterinaries eh
which is just the deep powers
and then you have this symmetric
order rank
which is the smallest r
or the or the wearing rank
of p it's the smallest
so p
polynomial
it's the smallest r such that
d is some x1 to the plus
g
so this is let's call that r and then we
have r under bar so lsr such that p
is a limit of
like this
so
these are things that rank
at most
rank r
these are things about rank um
order rank are
and the question is how to how different
can these two numbers be
so there exists does there exist
a sequence
the
j where the um
the growth
of pj
is is greater than a
polynomial in the grave of the border
rank
and and the conjecture is no
um so those two should coincide
no they do not coincide in general
so
so the the order rank
and so if i look at the polynomial x x
square x to the d minus one y right
that has border rank equal to two
and rank equal to what is it d minus one
or d minus
d over two something like that d
so here you have two and d
so that could be very different
but still d is grows like a polynomial a
polynomial in two
all right so i have to make the question
one yeah yes because the second i think
it is
in the number of variables yeah so so
polynomial
uh
in dn number of variables
oh whatever
nobody has to make besides though yeah
no i i agree i should be made precise
so
otherwise the answer is true exactly
yeah so let's see so we have
n the number of variables
and d but you could just let's just set
n equal to d without any loss of
generality so we have only one parameter
to worry about
and
so
what we want
is a big gap that a gap between these
two that grows faster than polynomial
so r of t j
minus r of pj
greater
than it works different doesn't sound
good
another month that i'll have instead
precisely what's the um um i mean how
fast are these breaks these rings
looks completely unknown the only thing
that's another question i mean i mean
the bigger one but the bigger one the
maximum rank the maximum rank is known
to be at most twice
the maximum border rank
so but of course the maximum border rank
can grow exponentially fast in n
so you want to so if there's going to be
a counter example it's going to be
something of smallish
order rank
where the rank is close to maximal
that's that's the idea do there is so so
what's the maximum rank where is that
where is that i told you the only thing
that's known is it's
twice the maximal border rank and the
maximal border rank is this you know n
plus d minus one choose d
divided by what and
what do you want
you want the minimum border rank and the
maximum right yeah right
right the ratio to maximize
and that grow very fast
okay that's
question
he believes no
i think that's reasonable and i think
this is a very clean question and
algebraic geometry that we could work on
so i have a question about about this k
p and p i mean
that's motivated in part by your result
on little ridges and but is there any
other reason besides besides its hole
is in b
case
yeah yeah but the intuition comes from
the previous one
yeah yeah my intuition i mean not non
the liquid which is
i i couldn't hear it that's the
conversation
okay what i'm saying is that
it's very unlikely that
the things that has talked about
which none of us want to happen
would happen and i don't think
i think that none of those things would
happen
yeah
like
in this talk cycle
and it's like
in fact there is a theorem switch
not permanent but it shows if you know
how to make polynomial density of how to
make the randomization you can separate
permanent from the terminal it's not
completely formal and i want like
to note one very nice
very nice problem
in the
randomization so you probably need to
solve it
assume that you have a
polynomial p of f
in your x
1 x 2 so on
kill x n and they want to find one
concrete polynomial which is not 0 not
identically 0 on any subspace of
dimension say 10
what's the minimal degree of this
polynomial can you find
so your polynomial
i want to find polynomial in n variables
so attachment for every
for every vector space
vectors
of dimensions
p of
this in my opinion it's a very it's a
very clean question
like dimension so making dimension
argument one can show that there exists
a such polynomial
one can show that
polynomial of degree
the degree
uh
so
once you get their generic polynomial
we'll have that part yeah generic
phenomena will have this property now
like
where is it
yes degree
generic
but what happened with the symmetric
elementary symmetric polynomial of
degree 11.
it will be zero we can show what's
on some subspace really
yes
like it's maybe not trivial to see to
find subspace but like you can show
degrees too small like if degree is less
than uh enters above the above your
dimension one above your then in other
words he says n to the one tenth i know
but
and the reason it's actually dimension
argument because
if you work over complex numbers you can
show it towards not not a different
number
because
this
degree of freedom
is different
and like reason reason why we need a
size degree because if you look say on p
of
lambda one v
plus number two is here
you expanded as polynomial in lambdas
you get here some polynomial with a
i
i want plus
you'll expand it this way
and it's zero even only if
all these polynomials are zero at some
point
like it's maybe one
but in zero if all these polynomials you
can find like
some some points in
v 1 v 2 v 10 start with obvious pendulum
will be 0 so you cannot take it too
small
and but we can't you can find such
polynomial like we can show that for
generic for generic
generic polynomial this degree
will have its properties
and it looks very clear question
and this
you'll have like many
implications like in
german relation of polynomial vegetating
for error correcting codes like
and it's
like there are many other questions
i see so far if if dimension was not 10
by but one you would take the moment yes
then dimension one you can solve it and
for dimension two you can go for it's
not more
so so i mean i mean this this should if
it happens it's if there's some degree
where it happens and then it should
happen for
general politics
uh
so it's a
question it was discussed many times and
in any sense like in any sense that it
looks so let's say find any polynomial
but don't say generic version the next
paragraph is not explicit dimension
argument is not allowed
dimension or random arguments are not
one
number
but it's it's okay it's okay so i
show like
there's many ways for like so third
algorithm which right coefficient of
each
monomial in polynomial time
but i think in many people use
i think in shallow lip circuit
they think explicitly
is that what it is
you can write down efficiently okay you
have to write down coefficient
deficiency so it will not allow you to
make tricks like taking coefficients
like
irrational numbers or you know
so no no
no cheating like this or taking
coefficients which are e
why don't we just say uniform
uniform
but it's not a problem to know what it
is
but have you tried asking nate because
he gave me
and this is a question when
okay this is why i'm asking this
question now because i don't know satan
left today
because this is a question yes for
finding a hyper surface with empty
funnels
you know there could be some interesting
you know linear section or
manipulation one could do to the permit
to kill its final screen
that would be a way to take their paper
as a starting point you look at where
those phenol schemes come from because
they know where they come from
in some cases for the permanent
and then you try to kill those off one
by one by altering the permanent that
would be one strategy
so i don't know precise results but in
the morning nathan told me that like i
know schemes of hyper hypersurfaces
oh yeah
you can deposit
in
when given the description of alpha
and they give
that the description of alpha is just a
sequence of integers right so the input
is just a sequence of integers
the exponent and what you know so this
algorithm the normal model you know your
favorite computer program
you know any computer program that takes
integers and produces let's say it's a
zero one polynomial
we'll just say zero
surface yeah it can add multiple as long
as polynomials
well it's time to end this conference
happen so we have a very intense week
and i would like to thank all the
participants from
as the chair of the gct workshop
committee on behalf of the committee
i would like to thank all the speakers
for the great talks for all the
participants for their enthusiasm for
making this workshop a success thank you
and maybe we should thank the all
nighters
oh